you wrote that stephen hawking he
tweeted
stephen hawking asked what breathes fire
into equations which meant what makes
given mathematical equations realize the
physics of a universe similarly i wonder
what breathes fire into computation what
makes given computation conscious
okay so how do we engineer consciousness
how do you breathe fire
and magic into the machine
so um it seems clear to me that not
every
computation is conscious i mean you can
let's say just
keep on multiplying one matrix over and
over again and my gigantic matrix you
can put a lot of computation i don't
think it would be conscious so in some
sense the question is
uh what are the computations which could
be conscious
uh i mean so so now one assumption is
that it has to do purely with
computation that you can abstract away
matter and other possibilities there
it's very important what's the
realization of computation that it has
to do with some uh
force fields or so and they bring
consciousness at the moment my intuition
is that it can be fully abstracted away
so in case of comp computation you can
ask yourself what are the
mathematical objects or so that could
bring such a properties so for instance
if we think about the
models
ai models the what they truly try to do
or like models like gpt is
you know they try to predict a next word
or so and this turns out to be
equivalent to
compressing
text
and because in some sense compression
means that
you learn the model of reality and you
have just to uh
remember where are your mistakes the
better you are in predicting the
uh and
and in some sense when we look at our
experience also when you look for
instance the car driving you know in
which direction it will go you are good
like a in prediction and um
you know it might be the case that the
consciousness
is intertwined with uh compression it
might be also the case that
self-consciousness
uh
has to do with compressor trying to
compress itself so
um okay i was just wondering what are
the objects in you know
mathematics or computer science which
are mysterious that could uh that that
could have to do with consciousness and
then i thought um
you know you you see in mathematics
there is something called cadal theorem
which means okay you have if you have
sufficiently complicated mathematical
system it is possible to point the
mathematical system back on itself in
computer sense there is uh something
called helping problem it's it's
somewhat similar construction so i
thought that you know if we believe that
that the
that
under assumption that consciousness has
to do with uh with compression
uh
then you could imagine that the the azir
keep on compressing things then at some
point it actually makes sense
for the compressor to compress itself
metacompression yeah consciousness is
metacompression
that's uh that's and i and an idea
and in some sense you know the crazy
thank you so uh
but do you think if we think of a
touring machine a universal turing
machine
can that achieve
consciousness
so is there some
thing beyond our traditional definition
of computation that's required so it's a
specific computation and i said this
computation has to do with compression
and
the compression itself maybe other way
of putting it is like you are internally
creating the model of reality
in order like it's okay you try inside
to simplify reality in order to predict
what's gonna happen
and that also feels somewhat similar to
how i think actually about my own
conscious experience so clearly i don't
have access to reality the only access
to reality is through you know cable
going to my brain and my brain is
creating a simulation of reality and i
have access to the simulation of reality
you